hello I'm Michael hi I'm and I'm joined
by jean-luc psyche hello we are the
persona boys here in the GameSpot office
and we are super hyped up because we
just watched the persona 5 royal trailer
it's gonna be sort of a definitive
version of persona 5 similar to p4
golden and p3 fests yep now what we're
gonna do here is watch the trailer and
point some things out that are new now
we're not gonna be able to catch
everything so instead of getting mad at
us
just drop a comment below of what you've
noticed so yeah this is the standard
interrogation scene that is constantly
referenced throughout because on five
yeah
but soon after this it cuts to the scene
that is taking place during Christmas
time right you can see in the background
so and then you get the voice of the new
character up on the screen here in a sec
and that makes me kind of lead to
believe that you're not gonna get her as
a party member until probably after
sighs dungeon yeah my guess now her name
is a custome Yoshizawa and yeah she's
pretty dope I like her design a lot but
he will do yeah we'll see that another
thing I want to point out is when the or
the screen turns on here in Shibuya it
plays the exact same sound as the
midnight channel in persona 4 I'm pretty
sure they're just reusing their sound
library and that's fine by me and that's
fine by me but I just was like I have to
point that out yeah it looks like she's
in the midnight Channel damn yeah okay
now you get to hear the the sweet tunes
we think this is the the new intro intro
theme yeah and then as well as just the
new intro visuals here they ensure our
animation it looks great yeah and the
song of course one of the best things
about persona 5 and all the series
actually is the music
I'm excited here new stuff from Lin and
show Chima Guerrero so yeah and you see
a little teaser of Joker's grappling
hook oh yeah they show throughout that
sort of his big thing is he has a
grappling hook now yeah we do get to see
it a little bit in action but to
actually play that like what does it
what how does it function how does it
function is it more of like a
context-sensitive thing or come on I'm
sure I doubt you can just like swing
away yeah you have to completely
redesign those dungeons to make that
work so the first thing we notice here
on his phone is a new area to explore
now this isn't just
one of those still scenes and hangout
spots that are in the original game this
is actually a place that you will walk
around and explore
it's called kichu gog you has an actual
place in Japan to like yep all locations
in this game takes place in Tokyo I did
a quick Wikipedia search on a key GOG
and it's apparently a popular hangout
spot for the youth um there's a lot of
shops and some fashion stuff so it's
probably gonna be more of like a
commercial district they said it's kind
of like similar to Shibuya but just
maybe like a little smaller scale yeah
so you can get a snippet of it here one
thing I noticed is on the mini-map you
can see some of the icons for shops and
there is a a little t-shirt icon which
makes me believe there's gonna be a
clothing store that was the thing they
added in persona 4 golden they added
like a clothing shop where you could buy
different outfits that make logical
sense to add something like that yeah
that'd be cool so yeah he's bunch of
restaurants and stuff oh here we go in
the silicon hug stuff
yeah and that was compa sheeta's palace
at least the outside of the castle and
like you said it might be like a
context-sensitive thing so we can get to
new areas in the palace because I think
one of the things that they're showing
in this trailer is like new areas in the
spaceport which you'll see later and
then new areas in comics Rita's Palace
right so it looks like there's like a
new puzzle in come cheetahs palace here
we get a glimpse of a cutscene a new
animated cutscene with custome and Joker
interacting there so you get a little
little taste of that I really like the
the animated scenes but there weren't
too many of them and they weren't as
vocal so maybe oh it's that a lot more
that was another thing golden did they
just threw in like 20 more anime
cutscenes yeah I'm here for it man let's
go so we have costumey who's gonna be
more involved in the Phantom thieves but
here is a new social link I'm sorry a
confidant I think they'll get those
things those two confused the same thing
yeah so he got a new confidant and he is
a school counselor his name is taka
tomar okey but the thing is is that you
only see in the trailer you only see him
interacting with on and also I'm
thinking that he comes in after calm she
does Palace to kind of set things back
right engine
I'm curious what his overall role is
gonna be because typically when they add
a new social link like in for and stuff
they kind of ended up fleshing out the
main story more they didn't really add
as many he was just another character
that's just sort of another character so
I'm curious if he is actually gonna have
like a somewhat of a role in the story
so here's a here's another example of
the grappling hook being used so you
probably be able to either get two new
areas or hopefully they can make some of
those puzzles in the space port more
concise so that was one that people a
lot of people don't like the space that
was finally yeah you and me were fine
with it but I can see how that can cause
problems but I don't know maybe that's a
way of making things a little bit better
for that palace here we can see Futaba
doing something new for us
yeah she's got an all-out attack that's
pretty cool that was a thing they added
in golden was like Avery's say a lot
more options boom now we don't get to
see her title card though no I want to
see that you see that you see that okay
and I want to see what that looks like
that's probably be dope and another
thing here that I guess from persona 4
golden is tag-team attacks or partner
attacks Morgan it turns into the to the
bus version of himself and then Haru
gets on top launches a damn grenade and
then like a badass oh my god while
Morgana rams into the enemy for a whole
lot of damage
this looks great I think it's like one
of the one of the cutest things you can
see Morgana here just out of it yeah
partner attacks were really cool because
I feel like it added a little bit more
chemistry to the combat system right and
yeah kind of build upon the
relationships throughout the game also
the background at first I thought this
might have been a background for a new
palace but when partner attacks do occur
the background just changes for the sake
of being stylish so I think that's what
that is back in the mid night channel
okay here we go so Mach toe is running
things because that's what she does
everyone's in their PE uniforms out in
the park I think this is by the pond I
believe the area and speaking of new
scenes right here we see custome the new
character who's gonna be with the
Phantom thieves
she's kind of getting in a tussle with
an adult cuz adults are [ __ ] in the
univer
so that's just how it be and Joker's
there to kind of intervene and I guess
that's one of the key development points
for her story and also next thing you
see is what I think is our persona
awakening first thought was her persona
awakening but she looks really nervous
now I was thinking maybe it's Joker
summoning his persona in front of her oh
and her like freaking out of it
that's my theory I think this might be
her awake I don't it could be within the
same scene maybe no doubt she'll have
her own a week of course for sure yeah
showing off some new areas here so I
think that one with Ryu G what's a new
new hangout spot you hangout spot and
then the aquarium with Yusuke I think
that of course you go to the aquarium
with Yusuke oh here we go
yeah and we got a penguin sniper which
is like a darts and billiards place and
immediately I thought of I thought a
Yakuza because they're both from Sega
dude Yakuza minigames in persona oh yeah
I don't think that's the case it seems
like it's more of you can invite
everyone and do like a kind of group
hangout maybe like get some get some
social links tats up yeah yeah I think
that's that's really interesting I like
you said it's probably not gonna be like
any mini games like I'm not going to be
aiming darts or aiming pools you'll see
in this in the trailer is that it's more
of like the whole group can hang out and
I was like you said I really hope that
it's it's a way to make the building of
social links a little bit faster or more
efficient I guess but also it's a really
cool spectacle it's like oh I got to see
because I'm when you go and hang out
it's always one-on-one but I want more
team bonding moment bonding right you
want you want to get a better sense of
they're all friends here
this is so this is a team attack we
mentioned earlier and Ryu G comes out
with the bat stun the enemy and then
mocked Oh channels in this Hokuto
Shinken style like Kenshiro Fist of the
North Star attack and throws a thousand
fists at the enemy man and that's dope I
don't know what else to say about that
but other than like Marketo kicks ass
man yeah now we get our first look of
costumey in battle now she has like a
fancy sword or whatever and then a
Winchester looking type of gun her
background is kind of a like a ballet
dancer I think in on the article on
persona central mentions that she's was
a rhythmic gymnast and so I think that's
kind of what inspires her outfit to be
more of like a leotard style thing to
call back to what she does in the real
world that makes sense also her mask
looks like she's straight out of
blood-borne or something yeah her design
looks really dope yeah and as something
you mentioned was that she actually has
pretty low espy compared to everyone
else so she's probably more of a heavy
hitter you know really emphasizes her
gun attack there so maybe yeah focusing
on guns more of like a Ryuji type and
then this is like a anime cutscene for
like a new scene we're not really sure
where it takes place we were trying to
figure out if it was like a previous
scene it kind of looks like a new
location I mean our guess is maybe a new
dungeon or something yeah this might
take place in a new palace I can't
obviously cow and fur dungeon sorry yeah
obviously we can't confirm that but
that's what it looks like inez here this
is when you kind of get the hint at who
costumey is and what she's about so yeah
she's a school dance
yeah just showing this moment actually
showing everyone up man yeah we haven't
had I don't know if we have had school
dances in Oh p3 or p4
so here you got a much broader shot of
Tokyo too kind of for me I looked at it
and thought about how much more
grandiose this game might feel with some
of its new content and maybe how it
might reconcile eyes some of the events
in the game so you got a nice view of
Tokyo in the Rainbow Bridge and Joker
overlooking it but man yeah there's a
whole lot of stuff in that trailer yeah
and we got a little bit more because we
got screenshots yeah so there's a whole
bunch of screenshots that came out of
Famitsu and we got these on persona
central panic those people out if you
want to see more of that stuff
yeah shout out to them and these word
these are screens that weren't included
in the trailer so we're just gonna point
some things out about these interesting
screenshots because hole boy there is a
lot going on here yeah the screen shot
of our new character here I notice in
the background you see the dice do you
think that's related to science Alice I
don't know I'm because I don't remember
there being a this looks like a
warehouse almost you were mentioning
that she might not show up as a phantom
thief until probably after the spaceport
because if you
notice and all the screenshots and in
the in the trailer custome is always
shown as a party member when harus in
the part right so she has to probably
come in after the spaceport yeah and and
also like logically if you were to try
and fit her in like especially if you
were to give her her own palace I don't
think it would make sense to do anything
until at least after Haru I also get the
feeling she's her story's gonna tie more
into a catchy because we see her and
akechi hanging out with Joker at this
great place boy loves his pancakes sure
do and her joining the Phantom thieves
is gonna somehow be kind of maybe tied
in they're gonna they're gonna tie it
into the events that happen with him
right like right after sighs Palace yeah
yeah all right we need to talk about
this oh god yeah dude all right
Morgana I can't handle it I well we we
don't we can't confirm Oh but yeah so
the blue eyes the the gold gold chain to
kind of like signify the gold scarf that
Morgana wears I translated and says that
apparently he uses a similar like speech
pattern like pattern as Morgana so I
mean come on oh how I feel about this I
don't know if we needed a human Morgana
I mean I'm all for a more fleshed out
story about Morgana because I do feel
like there's still loose ends by the end
of psi yeah there was some weird stuff
with Morgana that I felt like they never
fully explained yeah I was like but not
like this we don't need another teddy
but nah I'm not saying that Morgan is
gonna be on stoop to the level of teddy
but you know I have I have my doubts
reservations yeah her before so one of
the cool things I was added in persona 4
golden was a New Year's celebration
where everyone got together and watch
fireworks to celebrate the new year of
course so in the original persona 5 we
didn't get anything like this the tail
end of that game was like so fast so I'm
really hoping that by driving these
characters a little bit more fleshed out
through the story and having better
interactions and new scenes and all this
other stuff that this would also play
into that to where oh I get to the end
of story now everyone's back together
again celebrating after all the
hardships at the day of endure get a
little extra with them
gives you just more time to like let the
ending breeze and slowly kind of come to
a come to a head hopefully you enjoyed
our breakdown of the persona five royal
trailer and some of the screenshots that
we found as well stick to GameSpot for
more coverage of the game because we are
keeping our eye on it
[Music]